عسكره بحر الصين الجنوبيه مستمره من جانب
الصين التي تواصل تعزيز قواتها الموجوده
هناك تقرير لصحيفه
في الجزر والشعاب المرجانيه هناك جعل
الصين قوه بحريه في المنطقه المطله على
عده دول في جنوب شرق اسيا البحر المتنازع
عليه محاط بالصين وتايوان ودول اسيويه
اخرى لكن بكين تطالب بكل البحر تقريبا رغم
قرار محكمه دوليه عام 2016 قال ان
المطالبات الصينيه بحقوق تاريخيه في البحر
ليس لها اي اساس قانوني ومع تعهد الصين
عبر رئيسها لنظيره الامريكي الاسبق باراك
اوباما بعدم عسكره بحر الصين الجنوبي الا
ان الصين حولت هذه الشعاب المرجانيه الى
جزر اصطناعيه كما نتابع في الصور وبعدها
بعام الجزر المستحدثه باتت لعدد من القوات
والقواعد العسكريه التي تضم صواريخ وانظمه
رادار ومطارا ونظام دفاع جوي متكامل
بامكانه ان يطال جميع دول المنطقه خلال
الاشهر الاخيره حافظت سفن عسكريه امريكيه
على وجود لها في هذه المنطقه رغم محاولات
الاحتكاك التي تعرضت لها من سفن ومقاتلات
صينيه وعلى الجانب الاقتصادي تمر من خلال
المنطقه تريليونات والدولارات من التجاره
الدوليه التي باتت محاصره بين الجزر
الصناعيه الصينيه من الجانبين وبين جزر
سبارتلي وجزر باراسيل